[Musique]
ce métier je les aimais plus je les fais
plus je les aimais c'est à dire que je
lai approfondie j'ai essayé d'arriver à
oublier âmes oubliées dans mes
personnages
arrivé à me mettre moi-même je pourrais
citer l'exemple d'une pièce que j'ai
joué beaucoup qui s'appelait adrien 7
j'aborde un personnage comme cela il ya
dans le texte des points de repère que
je relis je me dis tiens là c'est moi là
c'est adrien 7 c'est l'autre et là c'est
moi petit à petit je relis tout ça et
puis petit à petit à force de jouer les
points de repères se font de plus en
plus proche
on arrive à de plus en plus près
d'adrien 7 est de moins en moins prêts
de soi c'est à dire que on a de plus en
plus de points de repères avec le
personnage et à la faim dans la
brillance est j'arrivais dès que je
m'installais dans mon fauteuil au début
de la pièce à être à derrière
[Musique]